well we step three step three is this is
where all the work is right prove prove
that it's true for now again think
engage your minds do not just go through
a set of steps because someone has given
you a nice performing that you can just
fill in the lines into right the next
step the next rung in the ladder is not
going to be k plus one is it right
because this is not K is it going to be
two K plus two that's the next number
after it why won't it be 2 k plus 2 yeah
2 k plus 2 would give me an
even-numbered on an odd one does that
make sense what is the next odd number
after this 2 k plus 3 ok now I'm going
to write out my statement and then I'm
going to go from there I will just begin
this for you I won't finish it because I
think you guys can manage it yourself
but I will start you off because even
once you write it it's still not a
hundred percent clear what you're going
to do with it
turn q okay as we've done in previous
questions I need a little bit more space
I'm going to start with the left hand
side now I want you to stare at the
left-hand side with me look at it down
here what would be the quickest path to
reworking or reshaping the left-hand
side such that I can use these guys up
here the assumption I wonder what you
can see hmm left-hand side let's just
write it verbatim first there it is okay
now what did I do with this slide to
make it easier to work with what did I
do
what's the difference between these two
hmm what do you see Decker yeah these
positive integers here that were up in
the index before they're much easier to
work with when I just see them as
multiples right that's all they are I
can do the same thing over here they're
just bigger numbers right how many three
of the two K's are there in here if i
factor out this plus three how many are
there what is three number three it's 27
right how many seven to the two K's are
there that's how many three in the two
case how many seven to the two K's are
there how are you with your powers of
seven seven forty-nine 343 don't worry
you have a calculator so you don't need
to have memorized that number but you'll
see it often enough that like I haven't
tried to memorize that you just see it
that's how many I have of this that okay
yeah what am I trying to get in there
what am i trying to find and the answer
is I'm trying to find these guys right
they're clearly in there how many do I
have of each hmm well three lots of
three to the 2k how many of the three
ton of three to the two K's do I have I
think I can see nine of them do you
agree with that nine lots of three lots
it's a bit confusing because there's 70
multiples but I'm just trying to see
this as clearly as I can what about this
one how many are there I want to see how
many seven lots of that there are well I
think there are 49 lots of seven lots of
that
you with me so far now what can I do to
make these guys easiest to see and do a
substitution well I want there to be
some even number of these I've got nine
of them here
so I can pull nine out of here as well
right do you see that nine lots of this
nine lots of this seven sorry if I
pulled nine out how many are left over
there are 40 left over which is kind of
suspicious to me because what is it that
I'm trying to prove was it I'm trim
proof I'm trying to prove divisibility
by 10 right now this is kind of I know
missus leaders already mentioned this
but when you're doing a proof by
induction just like when you're doing a
proof of a trigonometric identity you
always have to have your eyes going in
two directions right there's one eye
working and then it is another way of
looking at what's your destination where
are you headed right and when I see that
I'm like good see this guy here it's
done do you see that I don't have to
worry about it anymore it's clearly a
multiple of ten because it's 40 times
something okay what's over here what's
left I don't have to deal with this
anymore
what could I do with this that might be
useful
I can factorize out there nine right in
fact I'm even going to do there ya
better write it in long form like so
having factorized
I can now use my what's the thing about
mathematical induction the big central
piece is the assumption right it's the
only thing you do mathematical induction
never were us so I can say that's nine
times what get out of its way again 10 P
very good and because this is the
special thing about proof by induction
I'm going to say here that I've used the
assumption by assumption
do you need me to finish it or do you
reckon you could take over from there
all right I want to get to ten times
some stuff that's definitely a positive
integer I think you can see there's ten
times some stuff which is a positive
integer so I'll stop talking but I'll
finish writing it all out just in case
you want to have it for the sake of a
completeness and it bothers you having
an incomplete proof on the board but
that's pretty much all the hard work
there so the things you need to be
careful for are what is M and not just
anything right look for the conditions
around it because that will shape what
you actually do in your assumption and
in your proof step as well okay all
right I'll finish off writing it but I
think that's all the substance so you
can go back to whatever question you
were on or you can write it all down
with me if you like
you